TENNESSEE AMONG ANOTHERS.
NEIL BACK TO YOU.
NEIL: STEVE HERRIGAN THANK YOU
VERY VERY MUCH SO ARE SOME OF
THESE STATES PARTICULARLY
GEORGIA WHERE THEY STILL HAVE A
HIGH NUMBER OF CASES MOVING TOO
SOON LET’S RAISE THAT WITH PETER
NAVARRO ALSO THE WHITE HOUSE AND
TRADE AND MANUFACTURING POLICY
DIRECTOR.
PETER GOOD TO HAVE YOU.
>> GOOD MORNING, NEIL.
NEIL: WHAT DO YOU THINK OF
GEORGIA’S MOVE?
THE PRESIDENT WAS HOPING THE
STATES GETTING BACK TO
BUSINESS WAS CONCERNED THAT
GEORGIA WAS MOVING A LITTLE
AHEAD OF ITS SKIIS.
DO YOU AGREE WITH THAT?
>> I LIKE TO STAY IN MY LANE
AND VICE PRESIDENT PENCE IS
DOING A GREAT JOB ON THE TASK
FORCE SETTING OUT THE GUIDELINE,
BUT THE ONE VALUE ADD I MIGHT
HAVE TO THIS IS THAT TALK WITH
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE NOW ABOUT
THE CALCULUS.
WHAT WE KNOW FOR A FACT THAT THE
VIRUS KILLS DIRECTLY.
WE KNOW FOR A FACT THAT SHUTTING
DOWN OUR ECONOMY HAS DESTROYED
JOBS.
ITS CAUSED ENORMOUS STOCK MARKET
WEALTH LOSS WHICH GOES INTO
PENSION FUNDS.
WE KNOW THAT IT’S DOING
TREMENDOUS ECONOMIC DAMAGE BUT
THE MORE SUBTLE PROBLEM WHICH IS
A SERIOUS PROBLEM THAT COMES
INTO THE CALCULUS, NEIL IS THE
FACT THAT ECONOMIC
DISRUPTIONS KILL AS WELL.
WE LEARNED THAT WHEN CHINA WIPED
OUT A LOT OF OUR FACTORIES IN
THE MIDWEST.
WE SAW DRAMATIC RISE IN SUICIDE
RATES, AND THE OPIOIDS AND
ALCOHOLISM, DEATH TO CO-
MORBIDITY INCREASES TO THINGS
LIKE DIABETES, WE ALSO SAW A
SHARP BLOW FROM THE CHINA SHOCK
THEN TO THE FAMILY STRUCTURE.
WE SAW MORE DIVORCES, WE SAW
MORE CHILDREN IN POVERTY, SO
WHEN THE PRESIDENT HAS BEEN
GRAPPLING WITH THIS WHOLE ISSUE
OF WHEN TO GET THE ECONOMY BACK,
IT’S A DECISION THAT NO
PRESIDENT SHOULD HAVE TO MAKE.
IT’S PROBABLY THE TOUGHEST
DECISION ANY PRESIDENT HAS TO
MAKE BUT THE PEOPLE THEMSELVES,
BOOTS ON THE GROUND NOW, ARE
UNDERSTANDING THIS TENSION
BETWEEN THE DEATH AND
DESTRUCTION THAT THE CHINA VIRUS
CAN CAUSE DIRECTLY AND THE DEATH
AND DESTRUCTION THE CHINA VIRUS
CAN CAUSE INDIRECTLY BY SHUTTING
DOWN OUR ECONOMY, SO THAT’S, I
THINK THAT’S THE BIG PICTURE
HERE AND WE’RE STRUGGLING WITH
THAT BUT WE’RE LEARNING AS A
PEOPLE HOW TO FIGHT THIS VIRUS.
THIS IS A WAR.
IT’S A WAR THAT CHINA STARTED BY
HIDING THE VIRUS, BY HORDING
PERSONAL PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT
DURING THE TIME IT HID THE VIRUS
AND NOW, IT’S IRONIC IN MY VIEW
DISGUSTING THAT THEY ARE PROFIT
EARRING FROM THAT, SO THAT’S THE
BIG PICTURE.
NEIL: WELL LET ME ASK YOU ABOUT
THE CHINA PART OF THAT PETER,
COULD I ASK YOU?
>> SURE.
NEIL: YOU HAVE LONG BEEN VERY
CRITICAL OF CHINA EVEN THE TRADE
TALKS, THEY HAD TO VERIFY
EVERYTHING THEY DID AND WERE
PROMISING.
I’M JUST WONDERING NOW THEY MADE
A LOT OF COMMITMENTS TO THE
ADMINISTRATION AND THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE ABOUT BUYING A LOT MORE
GOODS FROM US BUT SEEING AS THEY
MISREPRESENTED THE SERIOUSNESS
OF THE CORONAVIRUS IN THEIR
COUNTRY, AND MIGHT HAVE HAD SOME
HELP AND ASSISTANCE IN THAT
REGARD DO YOU TRUST THEM TO MAKE
GOOD ON PROMISES THEY MADE TO
YOU?
>> NEIL, ONE OF THE MOST
IMPORTANT DOCUMENTS IS THAT
ISSUE THIS YEAR IS THE RECENTPEW
RESEARCH POLL.
IT’S AN  AMAZING POLL THAT SHOWS
THAT OVER 90% OF AMERICANS NOW
BELIEVE THAT CHINA IS A THREAT,
OVER 70% OF AMERICANS ACROSS
PARTY LINES HAVE AN UNFAVORABLE
VIEW OF CHINA, THEY ARE
CONCERNED ABOUT JOBS, THE TRADE
DEFICIT, THE ENVIRONMENT, HUMAN
RIGHTS, AND THE MILITARY, SO IF
YOU ASK ME, THE AUTHOR OF DEATH
BY CHINA AND THE COMING CHINA
WARS WHETHER I TRUST CHINA I
WOULD SIMPLY SAY THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE NO LONGER TRUST CHINA,
AND THERE’S SOMETHING THAT I
THINK --
NEIL: SO ARE THEY GOING TO MAKE
GOOD?
DO YOU WORRY ABOUT THAT?
>> LET’S LOOK AT THE PROMISES
THEY MADE.
THEY AGREED TO BUY A TREMENDOUS
AMOUNT OF OUR AGRICULTURAL
PRODUCTS.
IT’S CURIOUS THEY’RE NOW BUYING
A LOT OF BRAZILIAN SOYBEANS.
WE’RE WATCHING THAT CAREFULLY.
THEY ALSO PROMISED TO STOP ALL
OF THIS INTELLECTUAL PROPERTY
THEFT AND COUNTERFEITING, BUT
WE’RE BEING INUNDATED NOW WITH
COUNTERFEIT TESTS FOR ANTIBODIES
AND OTHER THINGS, AND SO DO I
TRUST THE CHINESE?
NO.
LET ME GIVE YOU THERE’S
SOMETHING CHINA WOULD CALL THE
FOUR KILLS.
I THINK IT’S WORTH GOING OVER
BECAUSE THE CHINESE EFFECTIVELY
DECLARED WAR.
THEY SPAUNED THAT VIRUS, THE
MOST LIKELY EXPLANATION IS
IT CAME OUT OF A BIOLOGICAL
WEAPONS LAB, PROBABLY BY
ACCIDENT, BUT WHO KNOWS BUT MORE
IMPORTANTLY, WE KNOW, THEY
KNOWINGLY HID THAT VIRUS, NEIL,
FOR SIX WEEKS AND THAT’S THE
SECOND KILL BECAUSE DURING
THAT TIME, HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS
IN WUHAN AND OTHER CHINESE FLEW
TO PLACES LIKE NEW YORK AND
DETROIT AND ALL AROUND, MILAN,
ALL AROUND THE WORLD EFFECTIVELY
SEEDING THE PLANET WITH THIS
WUHAN VIRUS AND IF THEY HAD
SIMPLY BEEN HONEST, HONEST WITH
THE WORLD THEY COULD HAVE
CONTAINED IT WITHIN WUHAN AND WE
WOULDN’T BE HAVING THIS
CONVERSATION.
THAT’S THE SECOND KILL.
THE THIRD KILL, AND CHINA’S OWN
CUSTOMS DATA SHOW THIS , WE SAW
WHILE THEY WERE HIDING THE VIRUS
, FROM THE WORLD, THEY
WENT OUT AND VACUUMED UP ALL OF
THE  PPE AROUND THE WORLD,
2 BILLION MASKS THEY BOUGHT
ALONE AND THEY TOOK IT FROM
COUNTRIES IN EUROPE, SOUTH
AMERICA, UNITED STATES, AND SO
WHEN THE PEOPLE, THE NURSES OF
THE BRAVE NURSES AND DOCTORS ON
THE FRONTLINES IN NEW YORK AND
CHICAGO AND DETROIT AND NEW
ORLEANS NEEDED PPE, PART OF THE
REASON THEY DIDN’T HAVE IT
IS BECAUSE OF THE THIRD KILL,
THE CHINESE THAT BASICALLY
VACUUMED THAT UP AND NOW THE
FOURTH KILL IS THAT THEY’RE
HORDING THAT AND USING THAT PPE
AS A WEAPON AND THEIR
POWER TO PROJECT IT AND TO
PROFITEER.
NEIL, THESE ARE $0.30, $0.50
MASKS AT RETAIL USUALLY
AND THEY’RE SELLING THEM COMING
TO THE HOSPITALS HERE FOR $7 AND
$8 AND SO --
NEIL: WELL IT’S PROOF THAT THEY
LIED.
THEY LIED THERE WITH THOSE FOUR
PILLARS THEY LIED FOUR TIMES SO
I’M JUST WONDERING BACK IN
JANUARY AND FEBRUARY WHEN YOU
WERE APPARENTLY SENDING SIGNALS
IN THIS MEMO THAT WENT TO THE
NATIONAL SECURITY COUNCIL AND
WORRIED ABOUT THIS APPROACHING
VIRUS AND A POTENTIAL PANDEMIC
THAT PEOPLE DIDN’T APPRECIATE
THE MAGNITUDE OF THAT BECAUSE
EVEN THEN, YOU SEEM TO BE
SENSING THAT THE CHINESE MIGHT
BE HIDING SOMETHING.
DID THAT EVER REACH THE LEVEL OF
THE PRESIDENT?
>> INDEED IT DID AND AS I WAS
WRITING THAT MEMO TO THE TASK
FORCE, ON THE TRAVEL BAN,
PRESIDENT DONALD TRUMP HAD
ALREADY MADE THE DECISION TO DO
THAT AND THAT WAS ONE OF THE
MOST COURAGEOUS DECISIONS
WE’VE EVER SEEN A PRESIDENT MAKE
HE TOOK TREMENDOUS HEAT.
NEIL: WELL NO DOUBT BUT HE WAS
ALWAYS CONVINCED THAT THE
CHINESE WERE TRYING TO DEAL
WITH THE CRISIS AND THAT --
>> I DON’T THINK THAT’S FAIR,
WELL THERE’S A DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN PUBLIC PRONOUNCEMENT AND
WHAT YOU ACTUALLY KNOW AND
PREPARE FOR AND I CAN ASSURE YOU
THAT THE PRESIDENT --
NEIL: SO HE HAD HIS DOUBTS BACK
THEN?
>> THERE ARE NO QUESTION, LOOK
HE’S ONE OF THE SMARTEST GUYS IN
THE WORLD.
HE KNOWS THERE’S TRUST ISSUES
WITH THE CHINESE.
NEIL THE THING THAT BOTHERED ME,
ME BEING THE CHINA WATCHER FOR
MANY YEARS IS THE FACT THAT
THEY CAME HERE, SHOOK OUR HANDS,
BROKE BREAD, GOT NEAR THE
PRESIDENT AND ON JANUARY 14
AND 15, NOW, THEY KNEW OVER A
MONTH BEFORE THAT THAT WE HAD A
PANDEMIC ON OUR HANDS AND THE
OTHER THING THEY DID NEIL IS
THIS IS THE WHOLE DEBATE ABOUT
THE WORLD HEALTH ORGANIZATION.
TRUSTED BRANDS PRIOR TO THIS
CRISIS NOW WHAT PEOPLE KNOW
IS THAT CHINA GAINED CONTROL OF
THAT AGENCY THROUGH A PROXY,
FROM ETHIOPIA, WHICH IS A CLIENT
STATE OF CHINA, AND BASICALLY
CHINA WAS ABLE TO HIDE BEHIND
THE WORLD HEALTH ORGANIZATION’S
SHIELD WHILE IT ESSENTIALLY WENT
THROUGH THESE FOUR KILLS AND
THIS IS A SERIOUS POINT IN OUR
HISTORY, NEIL, WHERE WE HAVE TO
DO FIRST AND FOREMOST IS A DEAL
WITH THE PUBLIC HEALTH CRISIS,
WIN THIS WAR AND ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT I’M DOING ABOUT
40-YARDS ACROSS THE STREET IN MY
OF THE OFFICE IS WORKING A GREAT
TEAM ON MOBILIZING OUR
INDUSTRIAL BASE AND SUPPLY CHAIN
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS ORCHESTRATING
THE MOST RAPID INDUSTRIAL
MOBILIZATION THAT WE’VE HAD
SINCE WORLD WAR II.
IF YOU LOOK AT THE VENTILATOR
ISSUE WHICH WAS LIKE THE ISSUE
OVER A MONTH AGO, AND PEOPLE
LIKE GOVERNOR CUOMO WERE RUNNING
AROUND WITH THEIR HAIR ON FIRE,
AT THIS POINT IN TIME, WE ARE
GOING TO HAVE MORE VENTILATORS
THAN WE NEED AND WE’RE GOING TO
HAVE PLENTY TO HELP OUR FRIENDS
AROUND THE WORLD.
GENERAL MOTORS, TO ITS CREDIT,
TOOK 17 DAYS TO STAND UP A
FACTORY AND TURN OUT ITS FIRST
VENTILATOR AND WE WERE ABLE TO
DELIVER THOSE VENTILATORS OFF
THE ASSEMBLY LINE TO HOSPITALS
IN GARY AND CHICAGO WITHIN THREE
DAYS, SO I’M SEEING THAT.
NEIL: THERE WAS NO DOUBT, THE
COMPANIES TO DO THIS WAS
VERY IMPRESSIVE BUT PETER I DO
WANT TO GET A SENSE FROM YOU NOW
WHERE WE’RE GOING AND YOU TALKED
IN THE BEGINNING ABOUT BALANCING
OUR ECONOMIC NEEDS, WITH OUR
HEALTH NEEDS.
THE PRESIDENT DID HINT THERE
MIGHT BE DISTANCING PROVISIONS
STILL IN EFFECT INTO THE EARLY
SUMMER.
ISN’T THAT ALMOST INEVITABLY
GOING TO MEAN THAT THE  V-SHAPED
RECOVERY HE HOPES FOR AND A LOT
OF PEOPLE SEEM TO THINK IT’S
STILL POSSIBLE, THAT THAT’S
HARDER TO DO, AS PEOPLE COME
BACK THEY CAN’T CROWD INTO
AS MANY RESTAURANTS AND
CERTAINLY THEATERS, IT’LL BE A
DIFFERENT ENVIRONMENT.
IT MIGHT BE A SLOW GO.
NOT AT ALL A V-SHAPE.
>> YOU BEGAN THAT DISCUSSION BY
SAYING I HAD TALKED ABOUT
BALANCING OUR HEALTH AND
ECONOMIC NEEDS, BUT THAT WASN’T
MY POINT AT THE BEGINNING.
MY POINT IS THAT THERE’S HEALTH
CONCERNS WHETHER YOU OPEN THE
ECONOMY OR  NOT.
IN OTHER WORDS THE VIRUS KILLS
DIRECTLY BUT IT ALSO KILLS
INDIRECTLY WHEN WE DESTROY OUR
ECONOMY, YOU GOT SUICIDES, DRUG
OVERDOSES, ALCOHOLISM ALL OF
THAT, SO THAT’S WHAT WE’RE
GRAPPLING WITH AND AS I SAID AT
THE OUTSET HERE, THE VICE
PRESIDENT, MIKE PENCE, ONE OF
THE GREATEST VICE PRESIDENTS
WE’VE HAD, HE’S DOING A FINE JOB
NAVIGATING WHERE IT’S A LEARNING
EXPERIENCE FOR  ALL OF US, BUT I
THINK THAT THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
WHO ARE LEARNING HOW TO SOCIAL
DISTANCE AND LEARNING HOW TO BE
RESPONSIBLE IN TERMS OF THIS
WHOLE THING.
NEIL: BUT DO YOU THINK IT’LL BE
A SLOWER RECOVERY AS A RESULT?
>> SLOWER ECONOMIC RECOVERY OR
PUBLIC HEALTH RECOVERY?
NEIL: RIGHT.
ECONOMIC RECOVERY.
THE  V-SHAPED ONE I WAS TALKING
ABOUT.
>> AGAIN I’M NOT GOING TO
FORECAST THAT.
WHAT I’M GOING TO SAY IS THAT
WE’RE DOING OUR BEST TO DEFEND
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE AND NURSES
AND DOCTORS ON THE FRONTLINES
AND DOING OUR BEST TO MOVE
FORWARD WITH THE ECONOMY AND
DON’T FORGET NEIL WE HAVEN’T
EVEN TALKED ABOUT THIS THE
TREMENDOUS WORK THAT
CONGRESS IN THE WHITE HOUSE HAVE
DONE IN TERMS OF STIMULUS.